Lucifer 5B is one hell of a season for Lucifans,
packed with laughter, tears, and destinies
fulfilled.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm answering the big questions
about how and why that happened to Lucifer,
plus what to expect from Dan, Chloe, Maze,
and the rest of Team Lucifer in Season 6.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
God's arrival on Earth is a crucial part of
Lucifer finally having to confront his issues
with his father and the rest of his celestial
family.
Despite the family dinner going badly,
Luci and dad are able to repair their relationship,
with God telling his devilish son that he
does love him just before he reveals he's
retiring and going to live with the Goddess
in her universe.
This sets up the climactic showdown between
Lucifer and Michael, the two final contenders
to take over the position of Almighty.
The two brothers face off at the LA Memorial
Coliseum, a fitting location given everything
associated with the word Colosseum, the most
famous of which in Rome was home to gladiatorial
battles and public executions.
Michael has the majority of the other angels
on his side;
however, because he doesn't have the unanimous
support needed, his attempt to claim the title
of God fails.
So, he tries to kick off a celestial battle
between the two sides, something neatly foreshadowed
earlier in the ninth episode:
"You have to play in the Family War Zone."
"Do I?!"
Chloe takes down a couple of angels with melted-down
demon blade bullets, and to avoid further
bloodshed the twin brothers agree to fight
each other.
Michael has the advantage of the Flaming Sword,
the divine weapon that Lucifer used to send
his mother into another dimension, and which
has the power to erase from existence even
immortal beings like Lucifer.
And when Michael slices a cut into Luci's
midriff, it's a call-back to what Dan did
when he brandished Azrael's blade against
Lucifer in the Season 2 episode "Trip to Stabby
Town".
"I know you ate my pudding."
As Lucifer and Michael struggle over control
of the sword, Chloe disables it by pulling
out the key.
And as Lucifer goes to pick up the blade,
Azrael appears.
"I'm sorry, Lu."
Azrael was Ella's special ghost friend in
the Season 3 bonus episode "Boo Normal" and,
as the Angel of Death, she shows up when somebody
is about to die.
Just at that moment, Michael brutally stabs
Chloe with Zadkiel's staff, which is –
ironically but also importantly –
the last remaining piece of the Tree of Life.
Chloe dies in Lucifer's arms, accepting she
was never to blame for Dan's death; so free
of guilt, she reunites with her father in
Heaven.
And the sandwiches you see them enjoying together
are an easter egg to the second season episode
"My Little Monkey" when Chloe made the same
ones for Trixie.
Egg sandwiches.
"A Decker family tradition."
[Chloe] So good.
"Grandpa used to bring me this sandwich every
Thursday after acting class."
"So good."
Lucifer refuses to accept Chloe's death, and
decides to go to Heaven to bring her back,
despite Michael saying his twin will die doing
that.
'You know, because of the whole "you're banished
from Heaven and would be instantly incinerated
if you returned" thing.'
Nonetheless, Lucifer flies up to Heaven and
survives the journey thanks to the immortality
contained in Lilith's ring.
When Lilith blew her immortality into the
ring it transformed from white to black, so
notice how the ring now has little white swirls
in it showing how the protection has been
activated and its power is being used up.
With some help from Mr Said-Out Bitch, Lucifer
finds Chloe and tells her she must go back.
Proving his selfless love for her, he takes
off the ring which is protecting him and tells
her:
"I choose you, Chloe, because...
because...
I love you."
This is a bittersweet moment once more for
Deckerstar fans who've been waiting for those
three little words.
"I was so ready to have my Deckerstar dreams
crushed again."
But the couple are separated again with Chloe
returning to Earth while Lucifer seemingly
burns up.
As Chloe comes back to life, Michael tries
to kill her again, but the resurrected Chloe
discovers she now has immense strength,
enough to go up against even an angel like
Michael, thanks to the necklace part of the
Flaming Sword that she's still holding.
And as she picks up Azrael's Blade, she seems
like she's on the verge of actually killing
Michael –
remember from Season 2 that the blade entices
those who wield it to murder.
However, Lucifer suddenly re-appears, pulling
the detective out of the blade's enchantment.
So how did Luci survive?
Lucifer himself doesn't seem to know; however,
there are several clues in Season 5 and earlier
seasons which can give us an answer.
First of all, we hadn't heard about Lucifer
dying if he tried to return to Heaven until
Michael said it in Season 5.
We know Michael lies and plays mind-games,
which we've seen him do to both Amenadiel
and God, and for all we know at some point
he managed to convince his twin of this fact,
meaning that if Luci believed it –
especially if it was tied to his own feelings
of guilt over his rebellion –
then because angels have the power to self-actualise,
he might have made himself burn up.
And perhaps it's that crucial moment of self-sacrifice
together with him accepting that he really
does love her, that rids him of all his feelings
of shame about whether he deserved to be accepted
back into Heaven.
That could, in turn, stop him from making
real the belief that he deserved to burn as
punishment for returning to his family home,
so in effect he saved himself.
Also, notice the importance of the word "choose"
in what Lucifer says to Chloe as he gives
her the ring.
"No, you don't have to do that!"
"I know I don't have to.
I choose to."
"What?"
"I choose you."
That echoes what Chloe said just before dying.
"We make our own choices.
I chose to be here."
Now, we know just how crucial the theme of
"choice" has been throughout the entire series,
after all, Lucifer has so often spoken about
his belief that he has very little or no choice
in life because of God using him and others
as, what Luci's called, pawns in his game.
"If you mean his plan to continually and control
me, then agreed.
It's my Dad's fault.
I mean, I'm sure it was Him manipulating things
like He always does."
So, it's absolutely huge that Lucifer recognises
in this moment that he does have the power
to make his own decisions.
And I think that his choice to give up his
own life so that Chloe could have a second
chance on Earth helped make him feel worthy
again and in control of his own existence.
And I imagine that this was what God hoped
for his fallen son all along.
"It's not up to me anymore.
You'll figure it out."
This idea of Lucifer making his own choices
in life and not making excuses for everything
by blaming his father
was an important point that came up in a previous
discussion between Luci and Linda about why
he didn't want to tell Chloe he was the devil.
"Because she doesn't have a choice, does she?
Neither do I!
It's all part of His master plan to toy with
us."
"That's an excuse.
You're doing the same thing as Him now.
By not telling Chloe the truth, you're taking
her choice away."
Tied in with this notion of choosing is Luci
being able to finally tell Chloe that he loves
her, something he almost did in the mid-season
finale.
Deckerstar hopes were temporarily scuppered
though after the disastrous family dinner
where God's somewhat cryptic answers to Lucifer's
questions about whether he ever loved him
made Luci believe he wasn't truly able to
love Chloe.
"I am my father's son.
Like him, I am incapable of love."
Again, because angels self-actualise, if Lucifer
believed he couldn't love then that would
prevent him from taking the final step in
acknowledging his true feelings for the detective.
Fortunately, by the time God decides to leave
with Goddess, he admits to Luci that he could
have been a better father, and then adds:
"I can say something I've wanted to for a
long time.
I love you, son."
This was an enormous emotional moment for
Luci as these were things he never expected
to hear from his father –
remember, Luci said as much after he heard
God Johnson say similarly emotional things
in season 2.
"You said some things that I think I wish
he'd always said to me.
I'm bloody furious.
'Cause I realized that my father would never
say those things to me."
But now, finally having this moment with his
real father is the reason why Lucifer's later
eventually able to say those words to Chloe.
With Lucifer's miraculous return from Heaven,
all the angels including Michael bend the
knee to him, signalling he has their unanimous
support as God.
And when Lucifer raises the Flaming Sword
above his head, you can see the Golden Sun
mural right above him together with Olympic
flames to either side, a nice reference to
Lucifer's name, the Lightbringer.
"Oh, my me!"
We can also see how the seeds for this epic
moment were planted all the way back in one
of Lucifer's therapy sessions with Linda in
Season 1:
"Before you fell, you were known as Samael.
The Lightbringer.
That was a name that connotated your father's
love for you."
We know that God finally told Luci that he
loved him this season, but in that Season
1 episode Linda also suggested that when God
cast Lucifer out of Heaven and into Hell it
was actually a gift:
"It was an act of love.
Because you are his favourite son.
But here's the thing:
When angels fall, they also...
rise.
All you have to do is embrace all that you
are."
She may have thought they were talking in
metaphors at that time, but as it turned out
the doctor was extremely prescient.
And by the end of Season 5, Lucifer did indeed
rise to Heaven after accepting that he was
loved by his father and embracing his true
feelings for Chloe, who notably was also a
gift from God.
And talking of Chloe, I noticed that Lucifer
made several mentions in the finale that it
wasn't Chloe's time to go yet and that she
was still needed back on Earth, which I think
is setting up a Season 6 plot point.
"The world still needs you, Chloe Decker."
Chloe's second chance at life is also a reminder
that second chances are essentially the overarching
theme of the series, with Lucifer even showing
mercy to Michael who was willing to kill both
him and the detective.
"In my time here on Earth, I've learned everyone
deserves a second chance.
Even you, Michael."
By the end of Season 5,
Maze too found she was given a second chance
at happiness when Eve returned to her and
our favourite demon discovered she'd grown
a soul through the time she'd spent building
relationships with people on Earth.
As for Linda, she reconciles with her grown-up
daughter who she gave up as a teenage mother;
and through her relationship with Amenadiel,
Linda has taken a second chance to form a
family with him and Charlie.
And when God comes to appreciate how he failed
his wife by neglecting her through his work,
he takes the opportunity of a second chance
to build a new life with her by going to live
in her universe.
Over the course of the series, Dan has also
reformed himself and grown to be a better
person.
He was, of course, cruelly killed in the fifth
season and, when Amenadiel visited Heaven,
he discovered Dan wasn't there as his lingering
feelings of guilt about his past mistakes
in life had taken him to Hell.
However, I think that with some help from
Team Lucifer in Season 6, Dan will find a
way to leave Hell and ascend to Heaven, just
like Mr Said-Out Bitch managed to do.
"I know I took your advice.
I faced my family.
My guilt."
"You went through the door."
"Yep, finally.
And boom, Heaven!"
Mr Said-Out Bitch's arc is a mini version
of Lucifer's.
They were both stuck in Hell in the first
episode of Season 5, with Luci agreeing to
help Lee find the source of his guilt which
stemmed from the time he felt too ashamed
to visit his family for his sister's baby
shower.
Although Lucifer berates Lee for his failings,
it's clear that the scene is meant to illuminate
Luci's innermost feelings about his own celestial
family.
"If you go through that door, it's only a
matter of time before you screw up again.
And so you'd rather stay away for all eternity."
"This isn't just about me, is it?
Whose Hell is this anyway?"
Like Lee, Lucifer decided to go through the
door to his family home when he faced up to
his shame and risked everything by returning
to Heaven, which in turn broke him out of
his own metaphorical Hell loop.
Likewise, Dan will need to find the key to
walking through the door that's keeping him
in his own personal Hell.
It'll be interesting to see what in particular
Dan feels so guilty over in Season 6 and who'll
be able to visit him to help him escape his
own Hell loop.
And like many other Lucifans, I'll be doing
another re-watch of the show to look for more
clues before Season 6.
But as much as we love our streaming services,
it can be really frustrating when the TV show
you want to watch isn't available in your
country.
Thanks to NordVPN, the sponsor of this video,
though you can make these geo-restrictions
a thing of the past.
Although some shows like Brooklyn Nine-Nine
and Friends are on a break from Netflix in
the USu, with Nord you can still watch these
on Netflix in other countries such as the
UK.
Use the NordVPN app to pick a server in another
location and browse the internet as if you
were there.
Nord won't slow you down either and you're
still able to get super-fast speeds when connected.
There's no bandwidth throttling and thanks
to Nord's secure, encrypted connection, you
get to keep your online activity private from
your internet service provider.
On top of that, Nord has a no-log policy so
it doesn't record or retain details of your
online activity when you're connected to its
service.
For a limited time, NordVPN are offering all
our viewers a huge discount plus one month
free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or go to the
link in the video description to grab the
offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
There'll be more Lucifer 5B videos coming
up, including easter eggs and things you missed,
plus Season 6 theories.
Tap here to watch the full playlist which
will have each new video as soon as I upload
it.
There's also a link in the video description.
So, what did you think of the Season 5 finale?
And do you have any theories on what you'd
like to see in Season 6?
Leave your comments below and if you enjoyed
this, then a like and a share are hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my next Lucifer video or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!